encore un obstacle pour plusieurs
l'initiation à l'acquis pop est arrivée
par cette vidéo désormais célèbre de
salon c'est ce qui est très familier on
s'en fout complètement hors de notre
zone de confort quand on écoute ce
qu'est pop puis ils ont créé leur propre
style donc c'est on aime ou on n'aime
pas dans les dernières années la musique
pop coréenne n'a cessé de gagner du
terrain en asie en europe et maintenant
en amérique du nord
[Musique]
nathalie sellier devenus fans de kpop
parce qu'elle s'intéressait à la culture
coréenne
c'est une façon pour l'accord est aussi
de donner un rayonnement culturel en
dehors de leur pays déjà en asie sont
très populaires mais ils sont en train
de se faire connaître maintenant dans
l'occident en fait il ya déjà plus de 30
millions de fans
en dehors de la corée mais percé dans la
k-pop est loin d'être facile beaucoup
seront appelés mais très peu connaîtront
la célébrité et les exigences pour y
arriver sont immenses les jeunes coréens
qui sont la k-pop aussi la pression de
la compétition de la performance il
travaille déjà très fort jusqu'à
s'écrouler et indiqué popp ont subi un
dur coup lundi en apprenant le suicide
de kim jong-eun membres du célèbre
groupe chinese on aime tous chagny quand
on est femme de l'époque même si on
appartient à une autre fan de parce que
ils représentent quand même en ce que
l'on est capable en plus quelqu'un qui a
été poussé depuis 10 15 ans à performer
paire formée par former c'est quelque
chose qui est très très très sensible
encore étudiant
les plus grands noms de la kpop se sont
déplacés pour rendre un dernier hommage
à john hyun dont les funérailles
officielles auront lieu jeudi
et ce n'est là ni boissonneault radio
canada montréal